bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you
subscribe to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to eight point six percent
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral you can use the description
right here
or you can go to blockfi.com to learn
more
all right let's get in this episode i
hope you guys enjoy this one
[Music]
all right guys bang bang i've got
catalina here with me thank you so much
for doing this
yes thanks for having me for sure let's
just jump right into uh your background
you are running for
congress but uh you spent some time in
the private sector and in the public
sector so kind of walk us through your
career
uh before you decide to run for congress
yeah and also i'll walk you through
just kind of my background so i was born
and raised outside of chicago
in a really small town my family came
here from
guatemala my mother's side and my father
built his own business he came from a
depression-era household
in chicago and uh you know they really
instilled the values
of hard work and liberty and free
enterprise
especially coming from a different
country where you come to the united
states and it's the land of opportunity
and so a big part of my platform is
preserving those values of you know the
ones i was raised upon but also the
values that really make the con
the united states the greatest country
in the world and
and so i'm really excited i'm now
running again illinois 16th district i
was in
illinois 14 previously in 2020 uh but to
really make change and i think
you know people of all backgrounds now
are starting to step up a lot of people
in the private sector are starting to
step up
because they see what's going on in this
country so i worked in the private
sector
i was appointed by president trump to
the u.s department of commerce
and really saw kind of firsthand how the
pro-growth policies from the trump
administration were really impacting
people in the district
meanwhile you see kind of the far left
rising the aoc's
this very socialist communist marxist
ideology
coming out from from women especially
the squad these younger voices
infiltrating the millennial community
and i took a a hard look
and said well who's fighting for our
values who is uh telling these stories
of
what it's like to to have family in a
different country and what opportunities
are here who's telling the story
from the business owner perspective or
from the the person benefiting from the
free enterprise
perspective we need new faces and new
perspectives so
uh and now i'm running again and it's
been an amazing experience uh thus far
but it's a hard job running for congress
for sure and so let's just talk about um
i think you know
what has become a uh a pretty
interesting
uh dynamic right if you look at trump
trump really understood social media he
understood how to
leverage a lot of the platforms to get a
message out speak directly to the people
cut out the middleman
uh and regardless of what people think
about uh his specific policies the way
that he communicated
uh was very very effective and ended up
obviously launching him into the
presidency
uh and uh and then kind of everything
that he did while he was
acting as president we've now seen other
people
realize the power of doing that and so
uh aoc and a number of other people
so it shows that it's not so much one
side of the aisle it's more just the
communication tactic is quite effective
and
um on the other side of that aisle and
sort of the democratic
uh viewpoint it seems like the message
uh is very much geared towards telling
people what they want to hear right
hey you're going to get free money
you're going to get support you're going
to get all these things
it sounds like you and the republican
side is much more around
free enterprise no one's coming to save
you and
you're going to have to kind of do this
stuff yourself and so
do you think that uh either side's
um kind of principles or perspective
really matters as much as the
communication tactic or
does it no everyone's going to use these
communication tactics and therefore the
principles the perspectives that's
ultimately what will prevail because
there won't be a difference in the
communication tactics moving forward
that's an awesome question and i
my theory on this is number one for a
long time
if republicans had the right messengers
uh we would be winning
right now for a long time in this house
that goes for both sides of the aisle
frankly is that you kind of have these
buttoned up people
that they go to washington they don't
really communicate with their
constituents you don't really know
what's going on
um and i and i think that all really
broke with the digital era
and the age and i call it the age of
authenticity where you have more people
interested in like reality tv
you have access to uh people
as human beings in a broader way that we
just never did before
based on the digital communication right
how come a ceo of a major fortune 500
company
or a tech company can get on a zoom
meeting
and talk to thousands of people
all across the entire world in real time
talking about the values of the company
or what's going on in updating the
company
but how come our elected officials
aren't doing that
there there is a gap in transparency uh
especially as you kind of rotate out of
a lot of our members of congress are
significantly older
i don't know the average age of people
um currently in congress but it's it's
not millennials
uh and so when you look at kind of the
the difference between the republican
party
and and uh the the democratic socialists
currently is our message still wins on
the republican side
but we need to have better messengers
and president trump was frankly
one of the first people to really break
that mold he broke that
kind of invisible uh wall between
the the majority of the population and
then this ivory tower in government
basically not only in the way he
communicated
but just being able to understand his
his base and what was incredible about
it is that uh
he was able to communicate to so many
people in the bible belt in the
in the flyover cities and fly over
country and
um also people of all different walks of
life i mean we've made
massive gains in in different um areas
and demographics and different
socioeconomic levels not only because of
his policies like you were mentioning
before but
but like you said the communication
barrier
and so you look at the socialists and
the democrats now aoc using kind of
these mediums of
video and twitter i mean she's got a
massive following
why is that because she's communicating
to an audience
uh and especially millennials to a base
her ideas are awful
but she's able to really capture that so
on our side
we need better communicators that are
really hammering down our message of
free enterprise personal responsibility
and and just going back and defending uh
the values of our country and the u.s
constitution
yeah and so i think that most people who
watch this podcast i've never talked
about this before but most people i
think it figured out that i'm an
independent in terms of uh
i frankly think that like the extremes
of all sides of the political
uh spectrum are uh probably missing the
point right
and so it gets back to this uh this kind
of like
the nonpartisan topics though that is
fascinating
that i think actually everyone agrees
whether it's you're more of a centrist
or you're on the extreme ends it's like
something like term limits
right where people literally say like
wait a second can should somebody be
able to
regardless of their political leanings
uh enter politics
at 25 or 30 and literally do it until
they die like that seems pretty crazy
especially
when you start to think about innovation
uh the ability to understand technology
and the evolution there
uh fresh ideas like just talk a little
bit about those
term limits and kind of you know what is
the right solution should there be term
limits
how should we think about you know those
being imposed uh
is should people be grandfathered in
should there be things that uh you could
do to maybe get around
term limits uh if you're a really good
um you know kind of governor of
of the people that you're elected to
govern how do you think about that
yeah that's also a great question you
know here in illinois
um especially i think coming from a deep
blue kind of blue state both sides
are you have this idea that both sides
are kind of just
career politician type of mentality
right and so this
term limits especially in a state like
illinois is a huge thing because you
have so many people that are there
for so long and then from a national
perspective that is happening all across
the board i mean you're right
people should not be in congress for 30
40 years i mean this is ridiculous what
kind of
um real world issues are you solving for
the future
you know when you're looking at things
like um how do we talk about
uh student debt or new innovative tech
innovative technologies how are you even
having those conversations
if if the mentality is kind of so i
don't want to say archaic but it's true
i mean they're
if they can't even solve real world
problems uh 30 years ago
how are they going to solve it presently
and currently in the future so i'm a
huge proponent for term limits
it's a an issue that both people
uh people from all walks of life
independents libertarians republicans
and democrats can
come to terms with but we but the
problem why i think it has never been
solved is because neither side
has wanted to solve it because a lot of
these people you look at
you know career politicians that is a
career for them
um when you look at the founders for
example our founders
they never intended to go to washington
for 30 years why because they
they had they were lawyers they were
farmers they had their own things going
on they had families back home
and not to say that you know politicians
don't have their own careers
but by and large they have made a career
out of politics
and so it's more beneficial for them to
kind of sit there and stay in
and do enough to get reelected and then
ultimately get there
what needs to happen because for so long
i think we've seen
you know the founders argued that why
don't you
vote somebody out of office then if you
don't want them to be stuck in there
forever
right unfortunately you know
politics has become such a money game it
has become such a
um it rewards the career politicians it
rewards
uh the kind of establishment on both
sides
and i'm really excited to kind of be in
this new generation of disruption
where a lot of these people now on both
sides of the aisle frankly
don't care um they're like i'm gonna
step in i'm gonna disrupt it we saw the
disruption in corporate america and
you know that's the rise of silicon
valley um and i think we're seeing it in
politics now
and so i'm really looking forward to
people champions from both sides of the
aisle saying look
i'm gonna go in there and i'm gonna
actually pass term limits because we're
young we're millennials we don't want to
be here forever
and and let's actually get things done
so i think you're seeing that shift now
so uh i think most people will agree
that uh 40 50-year
politician probably not the answer uh
and
i think that you i and other people um
you know kind of in our age brackets
will say like oh like just put a bunch
of young people in there the argument
against that would obviously be
wait a second all these young kids have
no clue what they're talking about they
literally are you know wide-eyed
bushy-tailed very naive about the world
and therefore they're going to make just
poor decisions not because they've been
around forever but because their
inclination or default is just go
disrupt them change everything maybe the
truth is actually somewhere in between
it shouldn't be that we protect the
status quo 100 but also we shouldn't
disrupt everything
and so how do you think about that
balance between uh
maybe fresh ideas and innovation but
also experience and
uh you know some of the things that
people who have been around for a while
have learned over time
yeah that's a that's a great um point i
think
a way to counter argue i think the young
um
bright-eyed bushy tale uh concept is you
know we have
a lot of people now millennials creating
billion dollar companies right i mean
they are successful we have new ideas we
are
um we are innovators and and a lot of
that is
is a generational thing not to say that
other generations haven't been able to
do that but we're cur
we have a lot of um a lot to offer
and on top of that you know you you
surround you're only as good as who you
surround yourself with when you look at
you know
the the capital or the capitol hill or
the swamp or
whatever you want to call it um there
are people who have been there
who know the game for so long you have
experts in different
um areas of you know policy wonks
to you know your chiefs of staff who've
been there for a long time have
have served under a lot of people and so
i think that's a really good happy
ground
is your team is having people that are
able to understand the concept
uh but then ultimately the the
candidates or the members
be new and it's not necessarily just um
an age thing i mean if you have somebody
who's significantly older who's
who's left the private sector or just
wants to step up and get involved and
run for office now
um there's a lot to say that too but you
look at you know what is actually being
um solved right if we actually ran
our our government like a business
if we actually ran things efficiently um
i think a lot of our problems would be
solved and i think we'd be able to come
together a lot more as a country as well
and actually say look let's let's talk
about these things in a thoughtful way
but you're seeing now you know i always
say hours
how's somebody in office for 30 years
but you still you're still talking about
the same problem
i mean you this is it so i
i think the the i'm more lean on the new
faces new perspective not necessarily
age but
just an experience in the political
space um does is not necessarily
i think um where our country needs to be
now
so as we think through uh there's the
age or experience level of
uh those who are elected to be leaders
in our country
uh whether they're old or young the
platforms are changing as well and so
where it used to be
kind of very much dependent on uh the
filters and the middlemen of the
traditional media
you had to go and talk to the new york
times you'd go talk to
the network television you don't have to
do that
and you can talk directly to people on
social media and other platforms but
at the same time that we're seeing a
rise in the adoption of that we're also
seeing
a rise in the challenges that those
platforms face whether it's
misinformation whether it's all sort of
different political ideologies
um so just talk a little bit maybe about
the social media platforms how you see
uh their role in all of this uh and you
know are there things that are kind of
out of bounds and they should
uh police or should we approach it with
a truly
free market approach of just hey anyone
can say anything and the platform is
just a platform it is not supposed to be
an editorial type
decision how do you view all that
absolutely i don't think that
you know these platforms should have
this bias and look i experienced it as a
candidate
prior to even when we saw president
trump being de-platformed
after the election censorship was
happening all across the board
and you know our argument as i'm running
as a republican
but this is a topic that a lot of people
should be concerned about no matter
what side of the aisle you're on is this
is limiting our free speech you know if
our founders didn't
want these monopolies or or a
government to be so gargantuan why
would they want this to happen in the
private sector
they are completely overreaching their
bounds and you see it i mean i remember
when
we were saying
this the excuse for for conservatives or
whatever libertarians
uh but it was it's really it's truly
happening and and i think the argument
too
is that we just want a seat at the table
we just want an opportunity
to to have these discussions and to have
a voice
at the seat of the table we're not
asking for
or or filtering anything out
we're just asking for a voice and
a big topic you know my a lot of
millennials
weren't even thinking about the election
at least you know some that i knew about
until president trump was d platformed
and
i know a big thing was you know how was
the ayatollah of iran
or some of these other world leaders
allowed to
have a voice and have a platform when
the president of the free world is not
i mean these are really concerning
uh questions that need answered
and and i hope that they get answered
because
this is a gross infringement on civil uh
unearned
individual liberties and again if they
can do that to president trump they can
do that to anybody
um because people should have freedom of
thought they should have
the ability to choose who they want to
speak with
who would they want to hear from uh and
that's just being very much
um stifled right now but at the same
time you can make the argument
why don't we have other companies come
in we live in a free market
society we have competition government
does not own twitter
and these other companies why doesn't
somebody fill that void
but then you saw what happened with
parlor where everybody kind of
came together and took parlor off of
even it be an
app as an app so
there are a lot of things that need to
be solved and i think this is an area
that
both sides can come together on as well
do you feel like as
there's uh other platforms that start to
pop up whether it's parlor or others
uh do you feel like there is uh
colluding
among the large platforms to kind of
attack those uh those competitors and
keep them monopoly
do you feel like no those platforms are
just like violating some of the terms of
service and that's why they're
being treated the way they are like how
do you do that yeah
and that's that's a tough question
because ultimately who's deciding the
rules you know what was
what was ultimately decided uh what was
the deciding factor rather
of parlor getting kicked off of google
and um
the android app store or sorry or the
iphone
um platform whatever it was whatever
app it was not being able to be um
purchased on or
or downloaded from what was the deciding
factor
was there collusion i'm not sure um but
it just kind of looks
bad when all these companies all of a
sudden decide to
uh take away another option
um that was clearly gaining some
momentum and in particular for
conservative voices
and so when you look at it like is there
a line and i'll
give you really extreme experience right
so if somebody is
actually calling for violence right
there there's a very kind of undeniable
uh call for violence not something that
could be interpreted as violence but
a call to violence or something that is
racist or sexist or kind of name your
uh thing that would be uh controversial
and potentially out of bounds if it's
like very obvious
should there be some limitation of free
speech on these platforms
or do you think that it's more just like
uh the truly free market
and the platform should happen to say
and who can use their platform
and what they can say and i'll carry out
the whole question like i don't know if
there's a rating
right i actually think that it's almost
more like everyone has an opinion
but i don't know if there's like a an
answer that we're all going to get to
that's like everyone wants to go that
that is the answer
there's a big issue with
choosing sides right i mean i have seen
a lot of situations on
facebook twitter you name it instagram
where one side is clearly
being told that they are racist or
misinformation and that you know you
have to put up all this
um hey with a caveat hey
do you you know this is misinformation
why don't you kind of look more into it
there is a clear bias that happened i
think if
if a platform is ultimately going to
decide
on what their bounds are in terms of
violence or race
racial comments or anything of that
nature then there needs to be a criteria
that is
is universal across the board with all
different types of people and that's not
happening right now
i mean there's countless examples of one
time
kind of being favored and and then again
back to kind of the parlor example
where you know if one person was
particularly calling for
violence or whatever it might have been
you shut down the entire platform
for the thousands of other users because
one person in particular was saying this
at least be fair i think if they are
going to implement these things
um and then ultimately i will say i mean
bullying and things like that it's
really tough on social media i'm sure
a lot of people on both sides of the
aisle also think that that
that's huge yeah is there an argument
don't read the comments and
don't get caught up in it sure but at
some point
like when somebody's death threatening
you or um
deliberately you know coming at you in a
very aggressive way
is there a line that needs to be drawn
as well uh
so that that's a it's a complex problem
um
but i think ultimately we just need to
strive for
for um equal playing field for both
sides of
for so all voices are heard
so another topic that has recently come
up is uh
diversity uh racism and
uh kind of everything that is related to
those
two um there's a very strong
push and i think most people would agree
an important push
uh on diversity whether it's in court
board rooms uh on executive teams
in uh the funding of uh companies and
founders
uh who the venture capitalists are all
the way to
on the political spectrum uh you know
kind of who the elected officials are
who
is nominated um and and who served
in a variety of different roles uh with
that said
um recently there was a politician who
basically said i'm
only going to vote for minorities
i'm only going to vote for a white
person
if they are lgbt um and so
at what point and where is i guess the
line between
uh the push for diversity which i think
most people again regardless of their
political leanings feels like that is a
an important topic uh all the way to
kind of what i would
think is a pretty extreme position of uh
you know race and sexuality how do you
just
view this balance and uh you know how do
you just think through it again
there's no right answer right it really
is i think kind of each person's
individual perspective
how do you think through that so i and
as a hispanic
woman um i talk about this all the time
of you know why are you putting people
on boards just based on their
ethnicity or based on their gender
or you know whatever it may be it should
be based on merit
and as the person say you are being put
on a board or
um you are being elevated in a different
position
wouldn't you want to be there because
you worked for it and because you
uh felt this this personal
responsibility
of yes i deserve a seat at the table
because of x y and z
when you bring in race and really
dividing people from
uh by color and by gender
you're basically you're forced to choose
um you're basically saying well one is
better than the other
and that's why we want to elevate this
particular voice or this particular
gender and i just don't think that
that's fair for the society i mean we
are
uh we are a country based on personal
responsibility
you have a lot of different people from
all ethnic backgrounds
in very different industries and
and people should should demand
accountability by merit not based on
this kind of
made up structure of
well you know that you're a minority
therefore you shouldn't have
therefore you deserve a seat at the
table because you have been for so long
um oppressed i don't believe that i
think we live again in the greatest
country in the world where
um all races are elevated and
and should be elevated based on personal
responsibility
not by picking and choosing we're in a
very dangerous spot when you
do choose and pick and choose because
ultimately
somebody is going to feel resentful for
that and
you know we should be encouraging um
diversity of
of thought and voices instead of just
again
diversity based on um identity politics
for sure and so i guess as part of this
this bleeds into
i think a whole bunch of other topics
when it comes to individual personnel
or individual responsibility personal
liberties um
and one of the things that uh also has
come up recently is uh
gun rights um and so there's a a really
i don't know complex situation right
when it comes to
let's say the second amendment people's
right to bear arms
uh combined with the safety of the
public and so there was uh recently
a mass shooting that occurred inside of
a supermarket
uh when people i think see the headline
they say hey there's a mastery that
occurred
immediately it's let's go and uh and
kind of install
much more um kind of stringent gun locks
right or gun control laws
uh what surprised me and again you know
i'll be the first one to say that in
many of these cases
uh you just don't know the nuances until
you start to look into it and you
really gotta kind of understand some of
it uh it seems like a rational argument
hey we should have gun control
uh and you know there's a spectrum there
right obviously having
uh you know id before you buy a gun is
some form of gun control but then
there's like very very stringent
outlawing of guns etc uh but in uh
colorado specifically it appears that
there was an assault rifle ban there was
uh you know
all sorts of mental illness type uh
rules in place and just a lot of the
things that people
normally call for around gun control
were already in place
and then there was still a shooting and
so is it something where
um you know using gun control as one
example of
many many of these topics where rules
can actually
change the situation or address the
situation or is it
just a thing where it's like criminals
and bad people are gonna do bad things
and
part of being a criminal is like
breaking the rules right like
and again i don't think there's a right
answer but i think this specific
situation as i've done more into it it
was actually shocking to me
uh frankly of like a lot of these
measures around gun control seem to
actually
have uh have been implemented in uh
colorado
yet there was still the shooting and so
how do you think through that
is there a right answer uh just kind of
you know if you were
an elected official how you would um
kind of act in this situation
yeah and what happened was was tragic
but we look at you're right i mean the
amount of laws that were already put in
place when you look at federally
the amount of gun laws that are already
passed from a federal perspective and
then individually i mean i live
you know close to chicago where we have
the strictest gun laws
possible and unfortunately you know 25
people were shot
just a couple weeks ago nobody in the
media really talked about that
a little boy was shot when you have a
situation like what happened
in boulder it's it's very sad that
you know people are are quick to
politicize things without actually
breaking down the facts um a big thing
that i saw too was you know the race of
the shooter
and all this stuff when we start talking
about
just everything from a surface level
perspective
um in the sound bite kind of era that we
live in
you're not you're the facts are not able
to come through
unless you dig really deep and and you
were right i mean the laws in boulder
how could have how could you you they've
done
they've put every single gun law
possible
um that could have quote unquote in
their eyes prevented it yet it still
happened right there are bad people that
do bad things it is the person
not the weapon and but when you look at
again
why our individual liberties were were
instilled in the first place
um we must respect that too for the for
the
overwhelming majority of law abiding
citizens and every time we
have these conversations when a tragedy
happens or we try to push more gun
control measures when there already are
some in place
then we are chipping away at that
individual liberty
every time and so the the focus needs to
be
yes is there areas to improve on in
mental health
sure let's look at that but let's also
look at why
you know i heard a statistic that not a
statistic i heard a um
i was reading about this and the fbi had
he'd already been on
you know the watch list or he had been
associated with somebody in the fbi
um watchlist he was on somebody's radar
and
again that's all the government
involvement that's all the control
possible and yet it unfortunately still
happened
we need to take a hard look at the
reality that that people will do evil
things
but no matter what the situation is it
should not be at the expense of
the law abiding free american citizen
and that's ultimately what gun con what
gun control
when they impose those things it
ultimately hurts the law abiding citizen
so uh we don't know each other super
well but uh i'm guessing that
uh you don't believe the solution is
just hey you know allow it to happen
um and so you know being meaning like a
mass shooting or a
significant negative event what is the
solution
right if uh you're running for congress
and you're in that seat
um and somebody says to you hey how do
we prevent these situations from
occurring
what do you think the solution is how
can you prevent
a um again when you have all the the
control
in the world possible in a situation
again like in boulder how can you
prevent that
um you've seen situations that people
who are
armed have been able to actually thwart
these situations or prevent more
killings from happening
a lot of these situations when you look
at the the mass shootings they happen
and i don't think this particular
instance was one of these but
you know schools are where where um
weapons aren't allowed
so ultimately the very vulnerable areas
that a mass shooter will go in and
understand that they are not going to be
met with
um a aggression back
right um that's a tough one to answer
but ultimately
i am for individual liberty preserving
our second amendment right as much as
possible
and people need to understand that again
criminals will get whether it was a gun
or whether or not
it was a truck or you know so a criminal
will
commit the crime that they want to
commit um and
again we maybe need to look at the more
the mental health issue that was
happening with that particular
individual
but in terms of gun control that's not
the avenue that i would be
um looking to solve the problem with
got it let's move on and uh talk about
immigration
uh your parents came here from another
country uh
and uh and they built a life for
themselves they've
i think it's you and your sister uh have
two uh highly productive
uh children they grew up uh in the
united states but it was all thanks to
uh them coming here from guatemala talk
a little bit just about
kind of the immigration situation uh
both
legal and illegal and kind of if you
were a elected official in congress how
you would address some of those issues
sure what
i'll first start out by saying that you
know some of these countries that a lot
of people immigrate from
my mother being from guatemala you know
you visit there and it's very poverty
um written i mean it is it's sad the
corruption
is rampant you have the the drug cartels
and the government
uh and law enforcement kind of all
together
in one system and and the the people who
lose
are the everyday working class people
there and that's why you see so much
poverty
is because they don't have you know in a
lot of these cases
um stable governments that or some sort
of stability
it's very corrupt and
but this is a this is a very complex
issue that unfortunately
a lot of past administrations both from
a congress from
a presidential administration
perspective but also
a congress has not been able to solve
in in a way that you know you're seeing
right now what's happening with the
border crisis where you're
you're having some serious issues that
are going on down there
and um why has it come to that point
um when my family came here you know i
i grew up with stories of my grandmother
working on a on a coffee bean farm when
she was eight years old because
education back in the 20s um in a
country like guatemala was just
it you know wasn't really even heard of
um
the literacy rate from the 90s you know
didn't even start to improve
until um the early 2000s in a country
like guatemala meaning you know
people couldn't even read how are you
supposed to have a
career or do better for yourself if
education or there weren't there wasn't
a free market type of infrastructure in
place
and so my family story again my
grandmother grew up
picked coffee beans as an eight-year-old
was able to start her own little
food truck and then ultimately started a
business
uh there but then it wasn't until my
family came to the united states that
they actually were able to
to thrive i mean when you come from a
country with poverty
you're not thriving at all you're just
living and then you come
here to the land of opportunity where
there's no ceiling you can start a
company you can come from nothing with
five dollars in your pocket and be
a billionaire you know i read somewhere
55
almost 60 percent of our billionaires
are all self-made
and i would i would beg to to also look
at you know the other portion of how
many
actually did start with a lot probably
not a lot
and and you know there are a ton of
immigrant success stories
um but the but the reason why those are
success stories is because you had
law-abiding people
who who came here because of opportunity
and wanted to have
a better life for their families you
cannot fault anybody
that wants to come here obviously
because we are the greatest country in
the world
but why have we imposed measures
that has incentivized
an influx of illegal immigration and
with that
comes their own um portion of business
you're looking at sex trafficking labor
labor trafficking um it's become a
business because
of past policies that incentivize people
to come here
hey you cross the border you'll get you
know health insurance you'll
you'll be able to get housing you will
be able to
you know get a paycheck these are very
things that
socialists and democrats ultimately
really do push for
is come here and we will take care of
you
instead of come here because
you are fulfilling a gap in from a
merit-based perspective you want to come
here you want to be a productive citizen
you want to pay taxes
you want to start a business you want to
create a family you want to
you want to contribute to our gdp in our
country
let's create a reform system that awards
that behavior
rather than awarding come here on an
illegal basis and we will give you
whatever you want
and this is a very complex issue that
both sides of the aisle clearly haven't
really figured out
but for first and foremost you need to
stop what's happened the influx of
people coming here is just
and when you have resources getting
taken away from you know border
or the border patrol or ice and and
things like that who are actually
targeting criminals um when you see this
influx you need to stop the bleeding
where it is first and then focus on how
we can actually bring people here on a
merit-based perspective
sorry a long-winded way no is it fair to
kind of um
say your perspective is like one we
should have less
illegal immigration two we should have
more uh and easier
legal uh immigration pathways
uh you're an advocate of a merit-based
system
uh and part of this is uh
to address the illegal component today
but also
counterbalance that with uh a drastic
increase in the legal immigration
pathways that people can pursue is that
kind of a fair way to categorize your
thought process absolutely merit-based
first but then also looking at let's
curb what's happening at the border
in a very thoughtful way and
again we should want the best and the
brightest you look at a lot of the tech
silicon valley big founders of
amazing companies doing incredible
things are
immigrants you have software engineers
you have people that are really
contributing
to making our economy thrive
and also obviously americans that are
contributing
of course but let's do it on a
merit-based
system first sure um before we wrap up i
want to ask a question
that i think just again spans across the
aisle regardless of what people's
political beliefs are
it's just how do we make more young
people care about politics and about
governance
about leadership uh in our country both
at the
local level the state level and the
federal level any ideas there in terms
of what people can do whether it's
within their own communities or what we
should be doing
at kind of a state or national level to
just get more people engaged
in politics in general yeah it's a
two-fold approach
um i'll use the example of what happened
with gamestop or even the twitter
example of president trump being to
platform
those type when when an issue actually
becomes personal
that millennials can really relate to
um and you have people leaders for
example i remember
um dave porton i talked a lot about
gamestop
um during that time when you have kind
of these mediums
that millennials are using and their
influencers talking about these real
world issues
i think it really forces people to kind
of especially younger people who
are not focused on these political
issues to look at
wow this is impacting my life um
i should kind of dig a little deeper in
this space
and then ultimately see the the
political policy
behind it a big thing too
is um educating people on history
you know and it goes back to having
effective messengers as well
in the political space of well these
ideas are not good
why because uh you shouldn't be taxed
you should be able to
you should you shouldn't be over taxed
you should have a little bit more money
in your pocket your 401k
should be up you should be able to open
a home you should be able to buy a car
all of that is made possible by free
enterprise a
a mixed economy and
you know once you kind of describe it in
those ways
from a philosophical in principle
perspective but also having the right
tools and the right messengers for it
i think we can actually really make
gains and a big thing
is um you know how can these influencers
that
are in the business space or really care
about these topics
that millennials are listening to um
educate people on on the policies
changes that are happening
right now you're seeing again the rise
of kind of the socialist
ideology because you have messengers
that are
kind of saying free everything let's you
know
let's over tax everybody let you know
let's control the means of production
by you know the state should be able to
to have control over everything where
if you ask the average millennial i'm
sure they're
in a good paying job they're they
they're trying to maybe
buy a house at this point they're trying
to have families
and that's only made possible because of
free enterprise
um so i know it's again long-winded way
of saying
you know having the right message but
having the right messengers for it and
the right mediums and
also putting out the facts and making
people think for themselves you know
nobody should tell you how to think
but you should at least have the
historical references you should at
least have the values and the principles
and digging deeper on
the fact that policy changes really
impact your life
um when i was with the administration
the tax cuts and jobs act for example
that was really impacting businesses
everywhere that was that was putting
more money in people's pockets
companies were able to reinvest in their
employees people's salary went up you
had low unemployment rates real wages
were up
those impact people uh that's the
message that we should be honing in on
and then you look at kind of these very
over regulatory
um burden burdensome rugged policies
that come out now from this
administration where they're looking at
tax you know people that have
200 000 or more when you're in san
francisco
how much is 200 000 even getting you
by with or new york city um
we need to look at these things in a in
a thoughtful way and i think millennials
are actually coming around
um to the idea of free enterprise and
ultimately that's a good shift we're
kind of getting away from
um the social issue kind of uh
construct and looking at well wow we
have a very
over regulated um
administration that wants to kind of
destroy free enterprise or at least
stifle it
how do we push back and how do we bring
back free enterprise
into the equation lower debt things like
that
yeah it's uh it's absolutely fascinating
and i think that uh
you know not every nothing is actually
free uh as we know
um but at the same time uh i think that
there's a lot of people
who obviously are in pain and suffering
is trying to find you know what is the
uh
um kind of middle ground is uh is why
the politicians are there and they're
going to do their thing and
they'll hopefully eventually figure it
out uh before i let you go i was asked
everyone the same three questions you
get to ask me one to finish up
uh the first is what is the most
important book that you've ever read
oh my gosh that's a great one um
man's search for meaning is a incredible
one i'll also throw out here the
fountainhead by ein rand
um is uh one of my favorites what's
yours
those are great ones uh i always say the
same three that were probably most
formative for uh for me it was uh
rishabh cornett
grew rich richest man in babylon
uh i was 20 years old and had a positive
impact so
uh those probably take the uh take the
cake um
second question sorry was i supposed to
say three
no no no whatever whatever you got okay
uh all right
next question is uh coming from our
friends over at eight sleep they've got
this thermoregulated mattress so you
make it really hot really cold
uh i used to sleep like five six hours
uh i started sleeping on this thing and
pretty much changed my life and i'm a
full-on convert of the sleep religion if
you will
and uh now sleep like eight or nine
hours what's your sleep schedule and how
has that changed over the years
that's an interesting question um
i would say i'm definitely in bed early
and i'm an early riser
that certainly was not the case in
college and probably after but
um i recognized that i need kind of a
structure to be able to
function correctly so um i go to bed
pretty early start reading
um and then ultimately kind of wind down
i try to turn off the phone
i know the lights are really bad you
know for sleep try to get a really good
night's sleep and then wake up super
early in the morning
how many hours do you think on average
um i would say probably
seven to eight hours full seven eight
hours
all right gotta get you an eight sleep
then it'll be eight or nine it'll be
even better
uh the last question is a more fun one
uh and you get to ask me one
is aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
oh i would say didn't something recently
come out this week of
some rumblings that were going around in
the alien community i would definitely
say that there are
a lot of questions that need to be um
answered
and there are a lot of things happening
that
um to say that there's not some sort of
um extraterrestrial being or community
it would be
um not looking at the facts
that's a very politically correct way to
say that you believe in aliens no
problem
uh you get to ask me one question to
finish up what do you got for me
okay um favorite company
why i don't know this is like choosing
between children
um i'll say the one uh
it's a company that we announced uh an
investment in today so uh not
necessarily a favorite but just the kind
of recent device a company called
synthesis
uh elon musk started a school on space
like this campus for his children
uh that really focused on just critical
thinking problem solving
independent thought you know more of the
skills that are necessary to be
successful in life
uh rather than the rote memorization
kind of preparation for standardized
tests
and so the co-founder of that school uh
he's got josh
and his new co-founder uh chrisman uh
basically creative is a software
and they take kids uh between seven and
fourteen
and they put them in these uh virtual
environments and basically
give them a problem they give them no
direction no rules know anything
and just say figure it out in a team
setting and so it's pretty incredible to
watch these like young kids
come in they've got to learn leadership
teamwork creativity
you know problem solving critical
thinking etc so that one
seems to be pretty important moving
forward if we can teach more people
critical thinking problem solving skills
i feel like we might be a little bit
better off than we are today
absolutely and that shows you that free
market
and innovation are
really filling these gaps where
traditionally
uh people kind of want the government to
fill you look at why is the
literacy rate so low in some of these
inner cities where
um how can big how can companies through
innovation
and again free enterprise be able to
kind of fulfill that gap and problem
solve so i think that's huge it's an
incredible
to know that something like that is out
there it's like school choice 2.0 right
the digital version yeah exactly
awesome listen thank you so much for
doing this where can we send people to
find you on the internet
uh or reach out if they have any
questions or want to
follow up yes catalina for dot com
and catalina lauf on all social media
platforms
awesomeness the benefit of having a
unique name is that you are not
competing with very many other catalina
laos
that is true that's true it's a it's a
double-edged sword
awesome we'll kind of listen thank you
so much for doing this and we'll have to
do it again in the future
yes thanks so much for having me on
again anthony you take care